- [Voiceover] So we have the graph
of y equal f of x right over here,
and what we want to do is figure out
the limit of f of x as x
approaches negative four.
So what does that mean?
Well, a limit is saying, "What
does my function approach
"as the input of that function approaches,
"in this case, negative four?
"As the input approaches a value?"
And as we see in this example,
the function doesn't necessarily
have to be even defined at that value.
We can see f of negative four,
you go to x equals negative four,
and you see that f of
negative four is undefined.
So this is not defined, but as we'll see
even though the function
isn't defined there,
the limit might be defined there.
And actually it can go
the other way around.
Sometimes a function is defined there,
but the limit is not, and we'll
see that in future videos.
But let's just get an understanding here.
What's going on as x
approaches negative four?
As x approaches negative four
from values greater than negative four
and from values less than negative four.
Well let's first think about values
greater than negative four.
So when x is negative one,
this is f of negative one.
This is f of negative two,
this is f of negative three.
This is f of negative 3.5,
this is f of negative 3.9,
this is f of negative 3.99,
this is f of negative 3.99999.
And so you can see the
value of our function,
as x gets closer and
closer to negative four
from values greater than negative four,
seems to be approaching six.
And let's see if that's true
from the other direction,
so from values less than negative four.
So this f of negative
seven, f of negative six.
This is f of negative
five, puts us around seven.
4.5, f of negative 4.1,
f of negative 4.01,
f of negative 4.00001,
it looks like it's getting awfully,
it's going to be a
little bit more than six,
so it seems as we get closer and closer
to x equal negative four, the value
of our function is
approaching positive six.